[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
could the man accused of selling drugs
to george floyd face third degree murder
charges in his death we investigate why
maurice hall's attorney is telling the
judge he plans to plead the fifth it's a
categorical hot mess plus minneapolis
police officers take the stand against
derrick chauvin could the thin blue wall
of silence be cracking sir is this an
mpd trained neck restraint
no sir
and the family of george floyd holding a
prayer vigil in front of the courthouse
as week two of testimony continues we're
going to get through this amen
law enforcement as always is terry
austin day seven in testimony in the
derek chauvin trial as prosecutors
present their case brian buckmeyer is
there for us and has more news from
outside of the courtroom brian
yeah angelica reverend al sharpton as
well as attorney benjamin crump came out
to give a prayer not only for the family
they said but also the community and the
country they talked about seeing the
video of what benjamin crump calls the
torture video over and over again and
how that's affecting the family through
a form of ptsd as well as he said all
the rest of us so they gave a quick
prayer
in the anticipation of both what we've
already seen and what we're about to see
and then mentioned we're going to start
to see the me or medical reports coming
up soon angelica
all right thanks brian well before the
jury was brought in for the day the man
who was in the suv with george floyd
appeared in court telling the judge that
he doesn't want to testify because he
could be charged with a crime law on
crime's angernet levy is here with the
major update to the story that we've
been following for you internet
yeah angelica we've been following this
for several days now maurice hall
fears he could be charged with third
degree murder or even more charges if he
testifies truthfully about what happened
that night last may
um the correct spelling for you guys
will be m-o-r-r-i-s
maurice hall in a code and tie appeared
in judge cahill's courtroom via zoom
from jail he has been provided no
immunity no protection for his testimony
whatsoever so why is hall so worried
george floyd's girlfriend already
testified that they bought drugs from
hall on may 25 2020 hall was in cup
foods with george floyd holding what
appeared to be cash he's also on body
camera video sitting in floyd's suv i
cannot envision any topics that mr hall
would be called to testify on that would
be both relevant to the case that would
not incriminate him well that's
ultimately the court's decision correct
yes drugs were found in floyd's suv
during two searches according to hall's
attorney and floyd ingested drugs when
confronted by police this leaves mr hall
potentially incriminating himself into a
future prosecution for third degree
murder but derek chovin's lawyer planned
to call hall to testify any events
leading up to their
mr hall and mr floyd's arrival at cup
foods earlier in the day where they were
what they were doing
mr hall's interactions with mr floyd in
the cup foods including whether either
party gave the other
a counterfeit bill
nelson said hall previously told law
enforcement that floyd fell asleep in
the suv before police approached the
prosecution supported hall's request
what we can't have
is an invocation of this privilege in
front of the jury
assistant attorney general matthew frank
says he doesn't want to give chauvin a
basis for appeal if he's convicted
opposing counsel has suggested that
almost an alternative perpetrator in
that sense
you know with the third degree murder
but there's also drug charges
counterfeiting false information it's
sort of a link theory former federal
prosecutor gene rossi says hall's
testimony only helps the defense he also
says hall could possibly face federal
charges for floyd's death if what you
did
in the chain
caused his death even if your link is
far removed
that could be a federal charge and that
is a mandatory minimum internet of 20
years
and a maximum of life meanwhile the
hearing ended without a decision thank
you mr hall
thank you good
now judge cahill said that the questions
eric nelson wants to ask maurice hall
should be written down in a draft form
and presented to him by this thursday he
actually called it homework which gave
people a little bit of a chuckle that
way hall and his attorney can review
them then this issue will be revisited
next monday judge cahill as you heard
ultimately deciding which questions can
be asked of maurice hall angelica
thanks all right there's more of this we
want to talk about terry over to you
first based on the judge's comments it
sounds like the scope of paul's
testimony will be very narrow we know
that so do you think that the parties
will be able to effectively keep that
scope so narrow
you know what angelica i don't i don't
think they're going to be able to put
hall on the stand and keep those
questions narrow the judge said he could
talk about perhaps how floyd appeared
and whether or not he appeared sleepy
but i think that is going to incriminate
hall because it will confirm that he was
in the car we know courtney ross said he
was in the car that's floyd's girlfriend
but we don't have that confirmed by hall
and i think once he gets on the stand
and once there's a cross-examination
many more issues will come out and if in
fact paul takes the fifth it is not
going to look good before the jury and
the prosecution raised that issue so i
think it's a very difficult situation
putting hall on that stand
all right and brian do you agree with
the judge here do you think that
regardless of the scope that there is
video evidence of hauling the car we
know that so that's incriminating as it
is isn't it
yeah but the difference between the
fifth amendment in an incriminating
video is that the fifth amendment
protects you from incriminating yourself
and i understand that he's not going to
talk about the pills or the sale but
just think about it rationally would you
tell a police officer that you were in a
car with drugs in it no because you
could also be charged with constructive
possession of those drugs so if he
describes what george floyd looked like
the only way he could do that is if he
was in the same vehicle with an
individual with drugs which in of itself
is a form of possession in many states
so that's incriminating i don't see how
the defense is going to get around that
nor the judge
all right and angenette part of what's
interesting about this is that hall has
already made some sort of statements to
minnesota state agents right
yeah that's right angelica um eric
nelson talked about that a little bit in
court today he said that there had
already been some statements made to
those bca agents when he was arrested
down in texas hall apparently said that
there were some pills that floyd had
planned to take when he got home later
that night he also nelson wanted to ask
him about why he decided to flee to
texas you know he was in minnesota and
then decided right after george floyd
died within two days or so that he was
going to leave so there were also
already statements he's made to law
enforcement pertaining to what happened
that night
all right thank you all we have more to
get to today on law and crime daily
officers taking the stand against derek
chovin as the prosecution presents its
case
and first neck restraints at the
minneapolis
[Music]
prosecutors are attempting to show
derrick chauvin's use of force on george
floyd and how it led to his death a
training instructor for the minneapolis
police department testified to what leg
restraints are and are not allowed
people that watch mma so professional
fighters they call it a triangle choke
and i use that term choke loosely that's
just what it's called but that's when
you place your
your leg over somebody's back
across their side of their neck and then
you trap their arm in so the person ends
up having one arm in
and
their arm causes pressure on one side
and the leg causes pressure in the
second
and you can actually
render somebody unconscious if you hold
that long enough
sir is this an mpd trained neck
restraint
no sir
has it ever been
not to my neck restraint no sir is this
a mpd authorized restraint technique
uh knee on the neck would be something
that
does happen in use of course that isn't
unauthorized
and under what circumstances would that
be authorized how long can you do that i
don't know if there's a time frame it
would depend on the circumstance of the
time
which would include what
the type of resistance you're getting
from the subject that you're putting
money on right and so if there was
say for example
the subject was under control
and handcuffed
would this be authorized
i would say no
meantime i'm cross the defense used
still images from the officers body cam
video asking the lieutenant about
chauvin's position
during the restraint
you can see mr floyd's head in that area
yes sir and mr chauvin officer chauvin's
knee between the shoulder blades of
mr floyd yes sir
does this appear to be a neck restraint
no sir does this appear to be a prone
hold that some an officer may apply with
his knee
yes
are there circumstances
in your career where you have had to use
your body weight
to hold a suspect down
for longer periods of time than say two
or three seconds
yes sir and are there times where you
have had to use your body weight to use
to hold a suspect down for 10 minutes
i'm not sure if i could have held
somebody down for 10 minutes or not i
don't have a recollection
is it possible
yes it's possible
all right so we heard about various
types of restraints and one of the ones
we learned about was the hobble
technique brian and basically the
prosecution suggested that since it was
not used that perhaps the need for the
use of force was declining so that's a
huge point for the prosecution there
yeah it's one of the few times we're
seeing the prosecution use what we see
in the video to try to give us a glimpse
into derek chovin's mind now they don't
have to prove intent to murder based on
these charges they merely have to show
intent to commit a felony and then a
death occurred with the top charge but
being able to show that the hubble was
not used definitely shows an insight to
derek trogman's mind that we haven't
seen thus far
all right brian thank you and terry you
know some of those still images showed a
different angle of chauvin using force
on floyd how do you think that those
images uh will impact the jurors
you know this is the first time i've
seen that angle angelica and i think
it's the first time that the jury has
seen that angle and it just might raise
some doubt as to how long tovan's knee
was on floyd's neck because all of this
time the prosecution has said that the
knee was on the neck nine minutes and 29
seconds
so if in fact some of that time the knee
was on the back i think it will raise
some doubt at least and the other thing
is the officer said that you know it can
be used but it shouldn't be used and
they're not trained to use it so i think
that will be something for the jury to
think about also okay terry bryan thank
you we have more coming up on lawn crime
daily more officers taking the stand in
uniform will break down their testimony
and what it means for ex-cop derrick
shovin next
[Music]
look back several police officers took
the stand and testified about policies
protocols and how aid should be rendered
in critical situations one even
highlighted that officers are taught to
quote use the minimum amount of force to
detain someone law on crime's kim
johnson is in minneapolis with the
breakdown on the officer's testimony kim
yeah the second week of testimony
started out with a focus on police
training several high-ranking officials
within the minneapolis police department
testified that the technique that derek
chovin used while kneeling on george
floyd's neck for more than nine minutes
was not within policy or training police
chief madera arendando testified that
chauvin should have stopped once floyd
was no longer resisting and talked about
how chauvin's actions did not fall
within the department's sanctity of life
values building on that a
sergeant-in-charge of crisis training
told the jury officers are trained to
give medical attention to someone when
needed and we know that no medical
attention was given to george floyd
before paramedics arrived and inspector
katie blackwell who was head of the
training unit last year testified that
neck restraints were allowed but
officers were only allowed to use their
arms calling chauvin's act an
unauthorized use of restraint
use of force according to policy has to
be you know consistent with mpd training
and what we train
our neck restraints the conscious and
unconscious neck restraint
so per policy uh
a neck restraint is compressing one or
both sides of the neck using an arm or
leg but what we train
is using uh one arm or two arm
to do a neck restraint
and how does this differ i don't know
what kind of improvised
position that is
so that's not what we train
now with the addition of two more
high-ranking police officers taking this
stand
testifying against one of their own
derrick chavin i can say that we are now
up to at least eight high-ranking
officials doing so uh and it's really
making people here in downtown
minneapolis question whether the
so-called blue li blue wall of silence
uh in unspoken code of officers not
telling on each other is crumbling
angelica
all right kim and going off that tell us
about the feeling there on the ground
you know how is the community reacting
to the testimony of these officers
well i would say it is mixed you know
this is not the first police officer in
recent past that's been charged with in
connection to a member of the community
dying but it is rather unusual to see
this many police officers coming out uh
in agreement that their uh a former
co-worker of theirs derek chauvin was
wrong in how he responded so there's a
sense of perhaps unity could come from
this but then i am also hearing from
members of the black lives matter
community saying that don't be so quick
to be hopeful that change is here they
want to
trust how police officers treat members
of the black and brown community on the
street versus in going off what's being
said in court
all right kim thanks for that when we
come back we'll have more on that thin
blue line the officers speaking out both
in and outside the courtroom against
derek shoven
[Music]
well as officers are lining up to
testify in court chief investigative
correspondent brian ross spoke to the
former minneapolis police chief about
how she views derek shoven's actions
coming up this week i'm brian ross
investigates we'll talk with the former
police chief in minneapolis about the
fact that the thin blue line often makes
it hard to prosecute police officers but
not in the derrick chauvin case
it's personally challenging to watch the
minneapolis police department being seen
in this light knowing all the great work
that was done by the men and women
during the 31 years that i was there the
mayor asked chief jenae harteau to
resign four years ago after a woman who
had called to report a crime was shot
dead by an officer muhammad noor later
convicted and sentenced to 12 years in
prison i'm constantly looking at things
can i
you know is there anything i could have
done personally to prevent this
i don't know the answer to that
former chief hartel told me she never
knew derek chovin but that she was
repulsed by what she saw on the videos
played in court yeah i
was just sickened and thought to myself
and actually spoke out loud i can't
believe i'm gonna watch a guy die on tv
the former chief says her efforts to
reform her department were often
frustrated by the police union yeah it
was beyond frustrating
i had terminated officers it would be
grieved you know even lower levels of
discipline would be grieved by the
unions arbitrators over 50 60 percent of
the time would overturn my decision to
terminate an officer
one time i terminated an officer and
instead of
the termination holding the arbitrator
thought two weeks off without pay was
sufficient
this guy actually the officer has soon
been since been uh
terminated because he continued to do
the things that i had saw him do and
tried to hold him accountable to
so it it does present challenges but
community activists also say as seen in
so many disturbing police body cam
videos there is a cultural racism at
play from myself as a black male growing
up in minneapolis
i've been pulled over jogging i've been
pulled over biking i've been pulled over
walking
i've been pulled over simply for being
black so don't get it twisted when you
when i say what the movement was it was
simply for being black there's been the
argument that derek shoving was just one
of the few bad apples but is there a
larger cultural issue with your former
department 99 of the men and women
go to work every day and do a fabulous
job
but there has been certainly i believe
systemic racism and frankly systemic
inequalities in every government
institution including police departments
that's coming up this week on brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network
all right continuing this conversation
brian coming out to you do you think
that it's unusual to see this many
police officers testifying against one
of their own typically we usually see
more tight-lipped cops
exactly uh but i say yes and no to that
answer the reason why i would say yes is
because yeah you don't see this many
officers coming out speaking out so
strongly against an officer but these
are unusual times you also don't usually
see a 9 minute and 29 second video of
someone having their knee on another
person's neck until they pass out
in front of us and so i think that's
what we're seeing but also these are
high ranking officers these aren't
mid-level or low-level officers who
worked with chauvin from day to day so
it's a very different calculus when we
talk about the thin blue line
good points brian and terry you know the
opinion of any chief of police is
obviously important but what did you
think about the testimony of chief aaron
dondo today
you know chief aaron dondo when he did
testify he talked about everything from
treating people with dignity and respect
he said that we owe citizens a duty of
care and if you recall way back when he
took his hat off when he spoke to the
floyd family so i think obviously his
testimony was important because he said
that chovin's use of force was in no way
shape or form objectively reasonable and
that was important but his whole
demeanor was important
all right terry brian thank you both for
being with us today and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
[Music]
you